welcome everybody to Long Prime daily
I'm Jesse Weber the defense in the Alec
Murdock double murder trial has
officially rested on Monday the jury
heard from experts who dispute the
state's position about how and possibly
when Paul and Maggie Murdoch were shot
and by how many gunmen lawn crimes and
Jeanette Levy explains from South
Carolina
my opinion is the totality of the
evidence is more suggestive of a
two-shooter scenario Tim palmbach is an
expert in blood spatter and crime scene
reconstruction he said he believes the
murder of Paul and Maggie Murdoch likely
involved two Shooters hey why would one
shooter bring two long rifles two long
weapons to the event you can't handle
and shoot two of them the opinion goes
against the state's theory that Alec
Murdock used two guns owned by his
family to kill Paul and Maggie palmbach
also said he agreed with another defense
expert who said Paul Murdoch was shot in
the head with the barrel of the gun
touching his head from behind not from
the side and in an upward angle as the
prosecution claimed prosecutors
questioned his conclusions and you just
got the chance to go out to Moselle was
it last Friday that's correct and so
between last Friday and today you've had
the chance to determine all of these
things you've testified about no before
I arrived here everything else was
predetermined and I had done all the
work in the analysis meanwhile Dr
Jonathan eisenstadt opined on the method
the Colleton County coroner used to
estimate Maggie and Paul's time of death
the coroner said he did so by placing
his fingers in their armpits you're
sticking it in an armpit which is
exposed to the ambient temperature
so uh that it's just not a valid method
to try to make a determination of time
just a guess where it part the
prosecution claims to call at least five
rebuttal Witnesses in its case for Law
and crime daily I'm Anjanette Levy in
Walterboro South Carolina
let's talk about the defense for a
second because one of the final
Witnesses the defense called was John
Marvin Murdoch this is Alec Murdoch's
brother and he described not only the
night of the murders and his brother's
reaction but also what he saw at Moselle
when investigators were finished with
the crime scene
and did you go to Moselle I did after I
left Greenfield yes sir and do you
remember who was there when you got to
Mozilla I was the first one there and
what'd you do
I just went to stay there until I knew
Buster of Brooklyn and elect for common
I suspected that other family members
and
partners because I I knew others were
coming so I just kind of sat there just
you know and just in disbelief still did
you eventually go down to the Kennels
um I did I did um you know
once everyone got there and it was just
there was you know a fair amount of
activity in the house with family and
law partners
um LX law Partners Randy's law Partners
um you know uh
I just felt like I needed to go down I
needed to see for myself what what had
gone on and just you know just kind of
take it in I mean
maybe for some type of understanding
and and was it cleaned up
um no Jim it was not cleaned up
for the skull fragments
yeah so
you know so so
excuse me oh this could be really
difficult
so I I could easily see where Maggie had
been you know I saw the night before
where the sheets were but and somebody
had told me that who was who and so I
could see where Maggie had been and it
was grass and you know they had covered
it up with dirt so there really was
nothing to see where Maggie was
um
I walked over to the feed room
and y'all have heard the descriptions
y'all saw it I've never seen pictures
and I've told them before come to this
court that I was not gonna see pictures
but y'all can imagine what I experienced
they had not been cleaned up I saw blood
I saw brains I saw pieces of skull or
and when I say brains it could just be
tissue yeah I don't know what I was
saying it was just it was terrible
um
and for some reason I thought it was
mine
something that that I needed to do for
Paul to clean it up
felt like it was the right thing to do
I felt like I owed him
and I started cleaning
and I promise you no mother or father or
Aunt or uncle
should ever have to see and do what I
did that day
and talking about that scene the defense
team actually wants the jury to be able
to see the property where Maggie and
Paul were murdered this is known as
mizelle it's around 40 minutes away from
the Colleton County Courthouse the
prosecution objected to this saying that
the property has changed a lot since
June 7th 2021 but the judge actually
agreed to the field trip defense
attorney dick karpoulian says his only
concern about the trip is security
literally dozens of people at Moselle
last weekend trespassing to get selfies
in front of the feed room I mean most
distasteful
kinds of things I've ever seen just want
to ensure that the security is not
caught unawares about what what a circus
is going to be outside the property and
they might they've got the authority to
close off the road so I mean I'm not
telling them how to do their job but I
am suggesting these are things that we
became aware of over the weekend all
right
we'll uh arrange for a jury view with
the with law enforcement all right let's
break it down I'm joined Now by my
co-host legal experts defense attorney
Brian buckmeyer former trial trial
Attorney Terry Austin Terry it sounds
like the jury is going to be able to
visit Mozelle I just don't know what
significance that's going to have is
that going to help the defense I don't
think it's going to help I think when a
jury goes out to the crime scene it's
really real for them and I think it
helps the prosecution because they're
going to be able to put themselves into
place and feel the whole horror of the
situation I think Council asked for that
because he said he wanted them to
understand distances he wanted them to
see the kennel and understand exactly
what happened that night but I think
it's going to backfire at the end of the
day and I think the Judge made the right
decision first of all defense counsel
was saying he wanted the jury to decide
whether they wanted to go home judge
said no it's up to one of you if you
want to request it I'll give it to you
and he did well focusing on the defense
for a second it seems Brian the defense
is creating this whole other storyline
as to how the victims died and that
seems like a stronger argument than just
saying the prosecution hasn't met their
case has improved their burden Jesse I
would say it depends if the defense has
a stronger factual argument based on all
the evidence that comes in and a jury
says hey I'm going to compare and
contrast these two different stories and
the defense seems better than the
prosecution yeah that can be strong but
I think it takes away from the defense's
strongest argument of saying probably
both one it's not my burden to prove
anything to you but I can show you why
the prosecution has failed two in me
proving why they failed this story this
sequence of facts makes more sense
that's why my client's not guilty rather
than trying to quote unquote prove Alec
Murdoch's innocence all right well
clearly a lot more to talk about so
still ahead on Long crime daily the Alec
Murdoch murder trial may be nearing an
end but our coverage is far from over
we're taking a closer look and a quick
break but when we come back we're going
to break down what a forensics expert's
testimony means for the case as he
disputes what was determined at an
autopsy
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody our coverage of
the Alec Murdock double murder trial in
South Carolina continues with more
disagreement between experts you see
earlier in the trial Dr Ellen reamer
testified about how Maggie and Paul died
she's the forensic pathologist who
actually performed the autopsies on the
victims and she said that the shot that
killed 22 year old Paul Came From Below
traveling upward but the defenses expert
disagrees
okay explain to the jury what she said
and then what you believe and we'll talk
about why the difference is in just a
minute sure so
um in her autopsy report she stated that
she believed the entrance was coming
from the left side went up and then it
exited the top of the head
um
to me this is a contact range gun
shotgun wound to the top of the head
that caused
extreme pressure build up in the head
from it being contact leading to these
types of fractures
and that the pellets
so the the shotgun wound comes in
the um wadding will start to open up all
of that pressure basically
for lack of a better term will explode
um what's there because the pressure
needs to get out somehow and then the
head would have been down like this and
the pellets lodged here and went into
the left shoulder and then you can see
that the pellets are going down into the
tissues of the left shoulder
so you believe the the
wound that resulted in his head
exploding was where where where would
the shotgun have been well it would have
been to the top back of his head and how
far away from the head oh no it would
have been pressed against that it could
be a contact wound to the back of the
head correct
to make a little bit more sense of this
on Law and crime network coverage of the
trial on Monday forensic death
investigator Joseph Scott Morgan did a
demonstration did a demonstration for us
using shotgun shells
we're hearing a lot about shotguns and
this sort of thing and I just uh I took
time to kind of create this I don't know
if you guys can see it this is actually
a 12 gauge shotgun round that has been
taken apart uh this fires but but I'm
sorry restart this fire is a bird shot
this contained bird shot very similar to
the bird shot uh that was used to kill
Paul now how this works is the anatomy
of the shell you've got the outer shell
okay once the firing is initiated by
tapping the primer
the ignition of the powder down here
takes place and it blows out remember Dr
eisenstatt was talking about kind of the
cylindrical shape of of the collected
pellets inside the body that means it
didn't have time to deploy Jesse that it
stayed all-in-one configuration as it
deploys a shot cup comes out you see
this you keep hearing them use the term
wadding
as wadding travels down range these
little leaflets on the side they deploy
okay and it when you if you look at any
of these you can see it in slow motion
on on YouTube these deployed it's almost
looks like a flower petal and it falls
away didn't have time to fall away that
gives you a sense of how quick this
happened
that means that the wadding travel
forward like this the the pellets which
are contained in here were delivered
through the wound and they stayed intact
not completely intact but you could
still make out the fact that they were a
collective shotguns are meant to spread
this round didn't have time to spread
that means it was in close proximity
this goes back to the idea of Shaving
the hair
what eisenstadt had said and what's a
good practice is as this weapon
initiates little flame comes out of the
end remember we're talking about
gunpowder igniting and it would have
seared that outer skin you'd even see it
on the table internal table of the skull
this was not done remember uh reamer
said the brain had been ejected out of
the body they didn't do an x-ray on the
brain Jesse right so that's very
important as well you have to shave this
area see the suit deposition you also
collect the hair and look for any
gunpowder on the hair I don't know that
that was done as well
thank you
both sides have rested their cases in
Alec Murdoch's murder trial in
Walterboro South Carolina and last
week's bombshell testimony from Murdoch
himself has given the 12 panel jury a
lot to think about but what is also
clear is that you our viewers have been
coming to your own conclusions at home
we have the results from our daily
YouTube poll and here's Monday's
consensus three days out from Murdoch's
testimony 65 percent of you think that
Murdoch is guilty 11 say he's not guilty
18 percent think that there's going to
be a hung jury and six percent are still
undecided these results pretty good
indicator of opinions from outside the
courtroom but we also have eyes and ears
inside the courtroom on a daily basis
here's long crime Zone and Jeanette Levy
and Gigi McKelvey discussing what
they've seen from the jury
I don't know what they were like on
Friday you were here on Friday I
remember you saying one of the jurors
had a blanket over her head and some
tissues in her ears I saw the blanket
jar today she seemed engaged didn't look
really look that pleased to be here but
she was listening they all seem like
they're still listening they're going
back and forth with the the tennis kind
of head the Bob they are listening they
are it's you know it's just a different
perspective of things that they've heard
about over and over and over you
introduce the two-person shooter Theory
which I think the defense had to do just
to get some Reasonable Doubt in there
they've been very attentive all day I've
kept a good eye for the most part on
them and yeah so I think maybe they know
we're in the home stretch too so let's
let's do our best and get all this in
our head and go back and get this over
well given that our last chat of the day
is going to answer questions not from me
nobody wants to hear from me but from
you at home so we gathered some of the
most asked about topics from today's
YouTube stream to hopefully make a
little thing a little more sense to
everybody Tara I'll start with you this
is a question from Caleb Mandrake out of
South Carolina this is all I should say
this is the question that he has are
South Carolina jurors allowed to take
notes or are they prohibited from doing
so and to make take it a step further
how does it impact the liberations in
the Murdoch trial good question Caleb
yes they are allowed under South
Carolina judicial procedures but it's
totally within the discretion of the
judge and as we know judge Newman here
said there will be no note-taking and
the rationale is look you listen to the
evidence and you make sure you go by the
evidence not somebody else's notes Brian
got a question from you from Brian
Clevenger can Alec Murdoch be found
guilty of just one murder or does the
state have to prove he committed both
murders well great name great question
I guess hypothetically speaking they
could do that they can say guilty of
killing Paul but not Maggie or vice
versa but that would be interesting how
they get to that conclusion that would
almost seem like they are crediting some
of the testimony and evidence but not
others and I don't know where they'd be
drawing the line if we got a verdict
like that I'd expect an appeal and they
probably would do fairly well because it
leads them to think well what did the
jury really decide or how do they get to
this conclusion based on the evidence it
would be an interesting verdict but I
don't see it happening that's a really
good question and I didn't even think of
that imagine if that act that happened I
would love to hear the jurors thoughts
on that Terry Bryan thanks so much
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here in Long Prime daily we're going to
see you next time as we discuss Justice
in America
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]